hello YouTube chest lovers and my
friends this is Gwynne Jen here welcome
to my fourth attacking chess game the
game which I have pick today is one of
the great beauty of the Kings gambit and
the interesting part is our recent world
champion Vishwanatha Annan was on the
losing side this game was played in the
Moscow 1995 between Alexander morozova
CH and Vishwanath Allen of course Allen
was not a world champion during that
time but soon after one year he beat
Garry Kasparov and become the world
champion so the only thing I want to say
before we commencing the game is if you
systematically attack even the world
champion can go down less than 25 moves
now regarding the models of which we all
know is a very good attacking chess
player and you will see in this game how
he completely destroyed the on earth
with a very good home preparation the
opening was Kings gambit so we have E 4
E 5 and one of the ways plays F 4 and
probably confident on his own ability
and unknown about the Morrow's intention
on and captured the pawn and here
whereas the which plays Bishop to c4
known as a bishops gambit line now the
people who see this position first time
may wondering why not Queen to h4 check
well it's very well known in Grandmaster
Circle that after King to have fun
Knight to f3 comes with a great tempo
and the resulting position is very much
favorable to the white and probably
unentered that murasa which is more
prepared for that line so he decided to
go for the main line which start with
this move Knight 12 6 and here white
plays Knight to c3 and onon replied with
the c6 so now you can see the idea is
very simple black wants to play d5 wide
drop the bishop back so Bishop goes to
the b3
and defy occurs anyways one pair of pawn
has been exchanged so across defy and
see cross defy and white plays d4 you
can see the first merit of this opening
not only white is trying to regain the
pawn at f4 but you can see there is
isolated pawn of the black on the d5 and
if the endgame occurs then it will be a
great position for the white so here
anin replied with Bishop to b4 so
pinning the knight and Morrissey which
continues with the kill site development
of the PCs Knight to f3 now when the
first time I see this position I thought
why not Queen to e7 check at this
position so Queen to e7 check and when
white plays Queen to e2 who black can
simply play Knight to e4 and I thought
this position is very much variable to
the black but when I checked with the
engine I found out that white has a very
simple reply Bishop cross f4 and no
matter how black captured that night the
resulting position is variable to the
white so for example if my cross c3 then
white can simply play queen cross Queen
and after King cross Queen white can
play Bishop to d2 again you can see the
endgame will be occurred and why it has
all the chances to win the game because
black has an isolated pawn
and if Bishop cross seats we here then
very simple will be B cross C 3 and if
now Knight cross C 3 then again Queen
cross screen and after King cross screen
white can play Bishop to d2 and after
Knight to e4 white can simply grab the
pawn at D 5 and the usual line continues
like Knight cross d2 King cross T 2 and
you can see at this position not only
white has developed a 2 piece but the
root will comes to the e-file of the
tempo and look at the black pieces they
all are at their original position so
this will be again a very comfortable
game for the white so considering all
this undecided at this point to castle
on the Kings side and why did the same
so white castle on the Kings side as
well and now here the best move for the
black is Bishop to d6 but instead of
that and capture the night and when the
white we capture the simple idea of the
black is to put the Queen on c7 where it
not only protect the f4 fall but it also
attacking the c3 murasa which plays
equally good move Queen to even so now
you can see this Queen is not only
protecting the pawn but this Queen has
an idea to go to the edge for our little
continues with the piece development so
Knight to c6 and Queen to h4 and now
Knight to e7 so Knight is rushing
through the King side
not only this night can use as a
defending purpose but you can see by the
arrows the knight can go to the either
g6 or the f5 where it can attack the
Queen white first of all grab the pawn
so Bishop takes f4 and now you can see
this Bishop is attacking the Queen so
animals has to forcefully capture the
pawn and after Bishop goes back to d2
and put his queen back to the c7 and by
this model you can see White has given
up his weak C pawn compared to the black
strong F pawn and after this exchange
where as which plays the excellent move
which is Knight to e5 and you can see
the first idea of Knight to e5 white can
any moment capture this knight on f6 so
for example if black plays a very
gradual move let's say a six then route
cross f6 and after G cross f6 white can
play Queen to G 3 plus and after Knight
to g6 white can actually capture that
night and you can see the Queen has been
attacked so black has to forcefully
capture the Queen but after Knight to e7
King to g7 H cross g6
not only White has a two piece against
the rook but the D pawn will be dropped
as well
the resulting position will be again
much more favorable to the white so
considering all this it's very important
at this point black cannot play any
casual moves and that is exactly I
responded so on unplayed Knight to f5
attacking the Queen and Queen has been
putted at very nice square Queen to f4
here onion develop his last minor piece
which is Bishop to e6 and now mother's
which played Bishop to be found
attacking the rook and the rook has been
put at c8 once the Roop more from that
file there's a one more piece going away
from the King and right now black pieces
are not that much actively place and
more always take a great advantage of
that you need a great courage to play a
move such as g4 that is exactly played
by the motors which undone drop the
knight backs to the d6 rook a to e one
has been played Allen played Knight to
e4 and the simple idea is cutting the
communication between night and rook but
after Knight to e4 the resulting
position is every single piece of the
black is going towards the Queen side
and that means this poor King has been
left alone and more other which exploit
this magnificently and he started with
the move c4 here the first mistake was
done by the onion and on uncaptured at
Paul and Morrissey which plays his
Bishop to a very nice diagonal bishop to
see to see how White has deflected black
from the Queen side activity and
suddenly white has switched to the King
side attack
and forcefully Aaron has to drop the
knight back to f6 and now can you
guessed it yes
SGI here the critical blunder by the
onion has occurred now here there are
two places for the night but it's very
hard to judge from this position that a
disaster is looming Knight to d5 is a
correct move but in the game on unplayed
Knight to h5 it looks very natural which
is attacking the Queen
but after Queen to f3 attacking the
knight black simply played g6 and now I
give you few seconds can you find a
winning sequence which will rip apart
the black
and I hope you find this move which is
night cross g6 stunning absolutely
stunning now at first sight it looks
like what is exactly going on but you
need to observe the situation very very
carefully now please note F cross g6 is
impossible because simple answer will be
route cross e six and not only wide
regain the peace but attack to boot and
a naked King so this position will be
disaster for the plan so very obvious is
H cross g6 and still it's not clear what
is wide achieving right now but now
comes a second dazzling sacrifice which
is Bishop cross g6 now it's very hard
for black to resist this sacrifice and
after F cross g6 white can simply play
route cross E six and now we have to
pause for a moment and see exactly what
we get after this - amazing sacrifices
first thing you notice is the normal
threat is this bishop and the rook is
attacking the knight the most critical
threat is white can play route cross g6
and then after Queen cross hatch file
that he leads to the mate and see the
poor position of the black rocks they
are not participating in any kind of
activities and that is the amazing thing
white achieved from this position
although white is a piece down nobody
wants to play as a black iron was
desperately trying to save the mid so on
and played Queen to f7
and attacking the Queen and what is the
which is not interested in exchanging
the Queen here
plate excellent move which is Queen to
d5 so Queen to defy by putting the Queen
on D file you can see the three pieces
are attacking the knight but not only
that that creates a discovered attack to
the Queen and to parry this all threats
black as only one move which is night to
fi but again I'm giving you a few
seconds can you find a winning shot by
the white and the wedding shot is yup to
cross a fire and here on resign those of
you who do not understand why done in
resign over here our sample line can run
like this if field capture work then the
very simple is rook check and no matter
where the King goes for example at say
King to g7 then Queen to g8 is a mate
and if pawn takes rook so G cross F fire
then very simple will be g6 now the
whenever Queen will move black has to
face the discover check and if the Queen
takes the rook then the very good sample
line runs like this so Queen capture
Queen and after King to g7 we have
Bishop to e7 and after King to at six
Queen cross fi black king will not
survive longer I hope you enjoy this
amazing miniature of the morozova CH
which will teach us if you are
systematically attacking to the world's
greatest even they can knock down very
very easily I hope you enjoy and learn
my fourth attacking game please feel
free to comment on my video and I will
meet you soon bye